hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga and we are continuing the
1858
london match between paul charles morphe
and yohanyako blemental
like we've said uh in the couple of
previous videos so far uh levanta lost a
match to the 12 year old morphy back in
1850 and now he wants to settle the
score and prove to everyone that he is
the stronger player
but so far not doing all that great in
the first four games one game was drawn
and the other three were won by morphy
so lointel still uh needs to win a
single game in this match to
uh well to to even hope uh have some
hopes of winning the match
and we're going to show the game now uh
very very exciting game
uh but uh i would just like to mention
that uh the feedy made it official
the candidates tournament 2020 resumes
on first of november
uh and if you want to learn more about
this there will be a link in the
description below first thing you see
yeah if you want to uh check out a bit
more info on that
so let's uh continue uh lentil with the
white pieces opens with e4
as he usually does morphe replies with
e5 we have knight f3
and morphe goes for the petrov defense
with knight to f6
we have knight captures on e5 going for
the main line classical variation
d6 knight f3 and now knight captures an
e4
so basically uh the same as if it was
played in 2020
uh we have d4 d5 and bishop to d3
so this is uh to date considered still
the main theory
bishop to e7 and uh here elemental
castles
uh the safety preparing to bring the
rook into the game knight c6
uh and here c4 and now uh nowadays uh
you wanna
react to this c for a move by either
going knight to f6
or knights to b4 both uh
well both uh add additional protection
to the
d5 pawn while this move also uh goes for
the light square bishop here but morphe
goes for bishop to e6 and this is a very
old move
and no longer played today so uh here is
where
uh modern engines ended the development
of modern theory
made some difference uh we have c
captures on d5 bishop
captures and bishop to e3 and it is as
of move 10 that this position has never
been reached again
uh we have castles by morphe and now
knight to c3 continuing development
threatening to pick up the knight here
as it's attacked twice and now
a f5 morphe uh strengthens the knight in
the center of the board we have
knight captures on the e5 uh grabbing
that light square bishop so morphy loses
the bishop
pair and the queen captures on d5 and
now longtail goes for bishop to c2
with the deadly threat of going bishop
to b3 which will win morphy's queen so
morphy of course reacts with king to h8
not allowing the capture
bishop to b3 uh remaneuvering the bishop
and the queen to b6 now and now
uh lointel grabs more space with d5
and now you could go to e5 for example
knight e5
captures captures and then uh something
like bishop to d4
which is which is very much playable uh
however uh
sorry about that however uh morphy uh
decides to go for knight to a5 instead
uh we have bishop to d4 just the same
and now morphy counters the bishop
right away with bishop to f6 so even
though morphy lost the bishop pair
he counters the dark square bishop with
his dark square bishop and he always has
the
uh well the the opportunity to capture
the light square bishop on b3
so rook to e1 lorentel just continues uh
developing pieces
and rook a to d8 morphe does the same
and here we have a trade we have
capture sun f6 captures on f6 and now
knight the g5 again elemental with
the threats knight to e6 is the threat
uh that will
uh win one of the rooks but morphy
counters with the threat of
uh queen captures on h2 and now it is
interesting if you go knight to e6
if you allow this then just uh rook to
e8 and you don't win any material
since if the knight moves if you capture
the rook then the rook also controls the
the escape square and queen to h1 will
just be checkmate
so after this knight to g4 move with g3
prevents uh queen captures an h2 and now
we have uh
just not a queen back to c5 uh you could
also just play knight captures uh
here on b3 uh queen captures and then go
for the
for the d5 uh pawn but morphy uh not
interested in this for the moment so
here
even though if you go for this it's
basically a draw for example you could
just trade everything off
capture so you could even capture with
the queen uh for example
uh let's say even or with the pawn
if you want to open up the the file for
your rook to have an attack uh
on the pawn here for example now you go
uh queen captures on the e5
knight to e6 and now captures captures
and here
uh rook captures captures and now this
rook will finally move for example
at the c8 as uh well the c pawn is under
attack
but even if you do this rook to c8
you're gonna allow this rook to come
all the way to d7 and now it's gonna be
well it's uh more fees up upon for the
moment but you're gonna win
one of them so not nothing uh nothing
special
here really happens so instead after
this um
after this uh queen to c5 move uh we
have a different idea uh we have queen
to e2 just
defending this f2 pawn uh so here we
have queen to e2 and only now morphy
goes for knight captures on b3
a captures and now again not going for
the d5 pawn but rather rook d
the e8 and this is uh well here it
becomes uh really tricky uh because
while you you could go for this it it's
uh it's very dangerous uh
uh to try that uh try and get too much
as you see morphe goes to rook d to e8
queen to f3 and now again not going for
the trade
probably going for the trade captures
captures and queen c2 is best because
you keep the pressure on the f2 pawn
and you also threaten these two pawns
you've eliminated one of the rooks and
you are
well you are very happy for the moment
however
uh instead of all of this after this uh
queen to f3 move
uh morphe goes knight to e5 and now okay
you're pressuring the queen if the queen
ever loses control of the f3 square you
might have some very
uh nasty checks happening but on the
other hand you allow
queen to h5 and now uh lentil is already
threatening checkmate so morphy needs to
defend against this
h6 and now rook a to d1 you could go for
captures captures and the knight to f7
check but that's
uh just trading you don't really get
anything so first rook a to d1 add
additional support to the d5 pawn
and keep all the pressure the knight
doesn't really need to move the pawn is
pinned so it's not a problem
here morphy goes queen to c2 queen to b6
uh is a bit more resilient as it uh
keeps
keeps an eye on the entire sixth ring
but after queen to c2
uh he allows a very very nice move by
lementhal
so even if you uh don't see it right
away pause the video and find this move
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the well the the the knight jump to e6
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight the e6 and
now
everything is hanging uh the rook is
under attack if the rook moves away from
the
from the back rank then this rook is
under attack if you don't do anything
about this then this knight is under
attack
uh also uh you can move the rook because
the queen guards this rook so the black
queen will not be able to capture it
so everything is nicely connected
however morphy finds counter play he
goes knight to g4 again there's the
problem of this
f2 pawn so first love intel needs to
waste the move to defend it rook to f1
and now morphy goes for queen captures
on b2 he sacrifices the exchange because
if you
uh if you go for something like rook to
g8 because you cannot move away from the
defense of this rook
then rook c1 then the rook can come over
here the knight can come to f4 to g6
it's
just gonna be uh it's just gonna be
incredibly difficult to defend this so
morphy instead
uh decides to uh capture the pawn
instead uh
and uh allow uh lemontal to capture the
exchange so queen captures on b2
knight captures rook captures and now h3
longtail doesn't want to this knight
constantly being here on g4 as as long
as the knight is here you will not be
able to activate this rook
so knight back to f6 attacking the queen
and now queen captures on f5 finally
and uh morphe of course grabs the b3
pawn
so now the end result of all that has
happened uh is that morphe is up upon
he's down the exchange
but he does have the two connected pass
pawns on the on the queen side so
d6 uh it's a very bold move allowing
morphe to create
three connected pass bonds on the other
hand if morphe uh ignores the pawn
uh then eleventh also gets a beautiful
pass pawn here so morphy
uh captures this we have rook captures
on d6
and now comes queen to f7 uh
helping out with the defense and also
keeping an eye on the pawns here
rogue back to d2 and now a6 morphe now
needs to find a way how to start pushing
his past pawns we have rook to e1
and b5 now and here queen to c5 not
allowing any pawn pushes as the queen
covers this also if you push you just
lose this pawn
so rook the e8 morphe wants to get rid
of
a pair of rooks and then he will try and
support the pushing of the pawns
with his knight and queen we have rook d
to e2 forcing a trade but
on e2 as you don't want to allow any
ideas like if the rooks move you might
have some
let's say queen captures or or something
like that king captures 94 check picking
up the queen
not while the queen is defending the f2
pawn but uh
could be uh could be uh you know
tricky so uh lemental wants to keep the
rook uh
uh uh as an additional defender on the
second rank so rook captures on e2
rook captures and now queen to b3
uh the queen now defends the pawn and
you can start pushing your a pawn
however
uh logantel also has a move uh so he
goes rook uh not rook to
it queen to f8 with check uh and morphe
now needs to decide does he move does he
block
uh if you go king to h uh king to h7
then it's uh very hard to uh decide what
to do here
rook is coming to e7 and then you have a
lot of problems here it will be
very very hard to defend you could go
queen b1 check let's say king g2 and
then bring the queen back
but then you will shift the the queen
away and go after the pawns this way
well it is possible morphy doesn't uh
like this idea
of moving the king so instead he blocks
check with the knight
uh and now we have uh rook to e7 now
threatening the
uh g7 pawn and this will of course be
checkmate so morphe will now be forced
to constantly keep an eye on the g7 pawn
and on the g8 knight so first
queen d1 check king to h2 and now queen
to d4
guarding the g7 pawn uh and now comes
rook the e8 now uh threatens to capture
the knight here we have queen to c for
defending
and now rook to a8 not uh giving uh
morphy uh
a moment to catch his breath now the a
pawn is being threatened
but not b4 defending the pawn this way
so elemental
uh re-maneuvers once again rook to a7
again threatening checkmate
and morphy again needs to defend queen
d4 with
defending uh and attacking of the rook
uh but
on the other hand you have to give up
one of the pawns sorrow captures and now
b3 if the pawn reaches b2 then it could
already get
very dangerous so of course uh white
will not allow that rook to a8 again
threatening the knight here
and queen to d5 we have rooked a7
again threatening checkmate and now
queen to d4 but now
rook to b7 putting the rook behind the
pass pawn and really
uh if you go for b2 here which seems
like a reasonable thing to do
after rook to b8 uh you you're gonna
lose the pawn either way because the
queen needs to defend uh
against checkmate and then you're just
gonna pick up the pawn so after this
rook the b7 move we have queen to c3
awaiting move by morphy uh but now comes
a a very strong move queen to f7 not
allowing any
future uh remaneuvering of the queen
along this diagonal and now rook to b8
you will not be able to do anything
about this so morphy needs to unpin here
if rugby 8 comes its game over so now he
plays king to h7
so if rugby it comes knight f6 can be
played but
uh after this uh king to h7 uh love
intel plays just uh
rook captures on b3 because now the
queen also guards that you cannot defend
against everything
so rook captures and now queen to e5 by
morphe so now
it's actually 11 who's up upon and also
up the exchange and it's going to be
incredibly difficult for morphe to
to to save this game so rook to b7 again
uh constant pressure here on the on the
g7 pawn
and now h5 morphe needs to start pushing
some pawns to create some openings
rook d7 uh and now knight to h6
uh we have queen to d5 now offering a
queen trade and
queen f6 morphe declines queen to d3
check
king to h8 and now rook to d8 with check
again the knight blocks and now
queen to d4 now offering a queen trade
uh morphy again declines and while uh
offering a queen trade uh he also guards
the f2 pawn so morphy goes queen f3 and
now
king to g1 now the king also uh defends
this
uh with king to h7 and now queen to d5
with an attack on the queen and attack
on the pawn and a double attack on the
knight here and here morphy really
doesn't have any choice he needs to
trade
so captures captures and now knight to
f6 morphe is now
uh down upon and down the exchange in a
rook against night end game
uh so uh if a miracle doesn't happen
here uh
leontal should win this game so will
this be uh lementhal's first victory in
the match uh well let's see what
happened here
rook to e5 and king g6 morphy starts
bringing the king into the game
f4 uh and now king to f7 we have king g2
uh longtail also knows that uh the king
is very important uh
in the end game so uh we have king back
to g6 by morphe
uh forced to wait and see what elemental
does with king of three king f7 and now
rook to a5 uh the knight is still on the
board so you don't want your rook
close to your king could be you know
could be very dangerous
came to g6 morphy again forced to play
waiting moves and now rook a6 spinning
the knight so king f7 and now of course
f5 taking away these squares from the
king
we have knight to d5 and now g4
uh we have captures captures and now
knight back to e7 we have king f4
improving the position of the king
knight d5 check with uh king to e5 and
now
knight back to f6 uh and here
uh love intel just played rook to a7
check and
it was in this position that paul
charles murphy resigned the game
and uh yohanyako blind got his first
victory in the match
so is this the turning point of the
match or is this just an anomaly uh well
we'll continue match and see what
happens but here of course you resign
because there's not much you can do
once the king moves uh for example
you're going to move the king king the
e6 is coming with some very nasty
threats the the pawn is coming
of course you cannot capture because the
threat of checkmate so you don't really
care you're just gonna keep pushing
and it's a very quick victory there's
even uh like uh
if you try something like knight to e8
you're gonna go rook k8 king the g8 uh
you don't have any moves here like if
you do this then you just get f6
and uh well you're you're running out of
moves g5
f7 and that's just it so after rook day
seven morphe resigned
and uh first victory for yohanyako
blumenthal in the match
uh so yeah uh that's the game i do hope
you enjoyed it and that you're enjoying
the
match between the two of them and the
saga so far uh there's always a link in
the description below if you're just
joining the saga do
do start it from the beginning as you
really want to know more about
the the genius that is paul charles
morphe if this is the only game you've
ever seen by paul moore if you don't
think this is like
who he is you know do do check out the
entire saga
so i would like to thank jeffrey johnson
and sid and for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the good
stuff checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the link in the description
below if you want to learn more about
the
fida candidates 2020 tournament see you
soon